fait été puni mais je voulais aller
jusqu'au bout et ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que ce que j'ai dit je
maintiens début des années 90 catherine
moyon de bach est l'une des première
sportive à briser l'omerta des abus
sexuels dans le sport à l'époque la
championne de france de lancer de
marteau porte plainte contre quatre de
ses coéquipiers pour violences sexuelles
lors d'un stage fédéral à l'été 1991 il
a sorti son sexe
après ils m'ont obligé à me mettre à
genoux quel point je peux pas dire le
win 8 passes de ton pénible des
agressions qu'elle affirme avoir révélé
à l'entraîneur de l'équipe de france
mais pendant le procès en octobre 1993
celui ci nie les faits tout comme les
athlètes incriminés moselle moyon
soutien des accusations qui sont très
graves elle soutient que on attenter à
son intégrité physique que ce soit par
voie l'attouchement parcours de baisers
j'irai plus loin
cela est farouchement contesté
un mois plus tard le verdict tombe trois
des accusés sont condamnés à des peines
de prison avec sursis pour le quatrième
c'est la relaxe
je suis écoeuré révolte et nous sommes
en france c'est la démocratie donc je
peux comprendre jugement du tribunal
mais moi je sais ce qui m'a fait je sais
ce qui s'est passé donc si vous voulez
je peux pas dire ben oui ça va malgré
les condamnations les coupables
reprennent la compétition à haut niveau
de son côté catherine moyon de bach est
évincé de l'équipe de france dans cette
histoire moi je ne je demande qu'est ce
que je deviens parce que encore une fois
c'est quand même moi la victime
alors qu'on essaie de me traiter comme
une coupable comme une perte différé
pour une brebis galeuses et je rappelle
quand même que je n'ai pas demandé à
être violée en stage national l'ancien
lanceuse de marteau réclame une action
du ministère des sports
la ministre michèle alliot-marie
sanctionne alors le responsable du stage
auquel avait participé catherine hill en
1997 son combat continue six ans après
avoir vécu ce drame
la championne de france du lancer de
marteau fait fi des menaces elle a
choisi d'écrire sa douloureuse histoire
dans son livre la médaille et son revers
l'athlète dénonce encore une fois la loi
du silence sur les agressions sexuelles
dans le sport je crois que sur un plan
général je peux affirmer effectivement
que c'est que ce genre de dégression
existe encore et sont couvertes et le la
loi du silence continue à régner depuis
d'autres sportifs victimes d'agression
ont aussi pris la parole aujourd'hui
le maire talent sur les abus sexuels
dans le sport semble se fissurer
[Musique]